Traduttore: Giulia Lucania
Revisore: Giulia Montevecchi
« Eredità digitali » è un tema
che nasce, fondamentalmente,
dalla consapevolezza nella quale
tutti noi viviamo oggi
che esiste
un insieme di informazioni
di cui in realtà
non abbiamo assolutamente
la percezione della dimensione,
che fanno parte
di questa nostra vita
e parlo di tutti coloro
che sono viventi
in questo periodo storico,
quindi non chi è nato
in una data piuttosto che l'altra
e che, tutti i giorni,
contribuiamo ad alimentare,
chi più o meno consciamente,
chi più o meno con etica.
Prendiamo questo insieme
di informazioni enormi
dalle quali
siamo pienamente consapevoli
del fatto che noi attingiamo,
ma che,
quando non ci saremo più,
sarà quel luogo
deputato a tramandare
quei valori
e quelle informazioni
che inevitabilmente
influenzeranno gli stili di vita
di chi verrà dopo di noi,
quindi le loro scelte di acquisto.
Oggi tutti i business moderni
sono fondati su questa cosa,
cioè come, attraverso la gestione
di questa enorme mole di informazioni
compreremo casa,
sceglieremo dove i nostri figli
andranno a studiare
e quindi modificheremo
la società nella quale viviamo.
« Eredità digitali »
è esattamente questo.
Per farlo,
vi chiedo
di partecipare attivamente
a questi dieci minuti
di talk
e vi chiedo di non spaventarvi
per i primi due, in realtà.
Vi farò tre domande,
in questo arco di tempo.
L'obiettivo è quello
di stimolare dei collegamenti.
Vi chiedo
di alzare la mano
se pronuncio
le parole
« Muro di Berlino »
e se queste parole
vi fanno ritornare alla mente
un'informazione,
non importa di che natura,
cioè quanto conosciate la storia.
« Muro di Berlino »
esiste dentro di voi ?
Siete il 100% ?
Fantastico.
Avevo 12 anni
quando è successa quella cosa
e purtroppo il mio ricordo
legato a quell'evento
lo vedete impresso
adesso sullo schermo
ed è abbastanza traumatico.
Non vi faccio la domanda:
« Chi sa cosa sta per succedere ? »,
ma vi ho portato
uno spezzone
perché a 12 anni guardi
Michael Knight, molto banalmente.
A luglio di quest'anno
History Channel
ha deciso
che per ricordare il fatto storico
del muro di Berlino
nel servizio che ha mandato
in onda via satellite...
questo è ciò che ha voluto
far riemergere.
Scusatemi...
In questo preciso momento
si inserisce
il significato di cosa
una variabile può influenzare
se ripresa a distanza di tempo.
Il fatto storico di cui
evidentemente tutti noi
conosciamo il significato:
l'inizio di quel cammino
che ci ha portati...
La giacca coi led.
(Risate)
Le parole sono
ancora più agghiaccianti:
« I've been looking for freedom. »
Non ve lo faccio
vedere tutto,
ma lo trovate su YouTube
senza problemi.
Vi risparmio
la fine del video
dove arrivano
due razzi incendiari
che cercano di colpirlo.
È una cosa
realmente accaduta.
Eccolo qua.
(Risate)
E due.
Un applauso a lui,
perché ha fatto questa cosa.
Ero al Tonks
a bere una birra
con Emanuele,
una sera qualunque.
Fuori c'erano Nanni,
Eva e altri amici
e mi ricordo che
gli stavo raccontando
di un fatto
di cui avevo chiesto
conferma a un amico,
uno storico
di politica internazionale,
la domenica prima
a pranzo,
a casa di mia mamma...
famiglia allargata,
quindi con amici.
Un fatto che Ruta
mi aveva raccontato
su questa cosa,
portandomi in università,
a Kaunas,
dicendomi:
« Ricordo il giorno in cui
mia nonna ha preso
me e mia sorella
per le mani
e ci ha detto:
andiamo,
venite,
usciamo.
Ci ha vestito con
i nostri vestitini tradizionali
e io mi ricordo
di questa cosa:
che siamo usciti in strada
e io avevo quella corona.
Quella corona lì.
C'eravamo tutti. »
In che senso, Ruta, c'eravate tutti?
Eh, tutti.
Il 23 agosto 1989
due milioni di persone
sono scese in strada,
nello stesso momento,
si sono prese
per mano
e hanno coperto
una distanza
che andava dal confine
sud-est della Polonia
fino a nord del mar Baltico
per 600 chilometri,
due mesi e mezzo prima
che crollasse il muro di Berlino
e hanno dichiarato
pacificamente
la loro indipendenza
dall'occupazione.
Scusate.
Questo fatto storico
che probabilmente
è una variabile
dirompente
nel fatto che oggi
abbiamo un'Europa unita,
perché è avvenuto quando
la Cortina di ferro esisteva ancora.
I media non ne hanno
parlato così tanto.
Su tutto internet
ho trovato queste foto.
È evidente che è
una variabile storica piccolissima
ma che rende, oggi che
la condivido con voi
e domani che la condividerete
con qualcun'altro,
completamente un altro impatto,
un altro scenario.
Questa cosa delle variabili
è importante
e c'entra tantissimo
con ciò di cui mi occupo
perché nella Biblioteca
del design di Milano
c'è la collezione permanente,
acessibile al pubblico,
più importante
sulla storia del design italiano
dai primi del 900
a oggi.
C'è stato un periodo
in questa nazione
nel quale chi stava
ricostruendo da zero
quella che sarebbe stata
la nostra eredità,
quella che noi
abbiamo ricevuto,
pensava negli stessi
termini di innovazione
nei quali si pensa oggi.
Quando non hai niente,
lo stimolo è altissimo.
20.000 volumi,
purtroppo cartacei...
Il progetto di digitalizzazione,
presentato a Expo
delle Startup l'anno scorso,
abbiamo cominciato
a digitalizzare il due ottobre,
oggi siamo arrivati
alle prime
100.000 pagine,
ha l'obiettivo
di distribuire gratuitamente
ai 100 migliori atenei
di architettura e design
della Comunità europea,
l'accesso a questo database
per un totale
di 100.000 studenti
che studiano design,
che significa « progetto »
e che progettano
la loro vita
e quella che sarà
la nostra vita di domani.
Due milioni e quasi 500.000
pagine di ipertesto
sono una mole
di dati che
sono piccolissimi,
pensando a quel magma
di informazioni
di cui parlavamo prima,
ma che hanno la capacità e il potere
di restituire un equilibrio
al fatto che la rete
esiste da 20 anni
e ciò che abbiamo generato
in termini di contenuto originale
esiste da pochissimo,
rispetto a ciò che noi,
come italiani,
abbiamo dato alla storia
del design mondiale,
a come abbiamo influenzato
la vita degli altri, inevitabilmente.
Quella bambina con la treccia,
che ha in testa la corona
che avete visto nella prima slide,
è la direttrice del Design Center
di Kaunas University of Technology,
principale partner del progetto
di Digital Design Library
e luogo fisico nel quale
verranno conservati
questi dati
e da cui poi daremo accesso
a tutte le università.
La domanda che voglio farvi
adesso per concludere e che
dà un senso a tutto ciò,
è condividere con voi
la consapevolezza che
ogni volta che mandiamo
un messaggio WhatsApp
a qualcuno che ci sta
aspettando a casa
o pubblichiamo qualcosa
sulla nostra pagina Facebook
o abbiamo accesso a queste straordinarie
« smart technologies »
stiamo contribuendo
a generare
un contenuto
per quella cosa
che domani
sarà il nostro lascito.
[Diventi responsabile, per sempre,
di ciò che hai addomesticato.]
Avere questa consapevolezza
significa anche averne del fatto
che ogni giorno,
in ogni piccolo gesto,
siamo in grado di generare
una variabile distruttiva
per tutto ciò
che invece viene immesso,
quotidianamente, su quella rete.
Distruttiva nel senso positivo,
prendetela nel senso
costruttivo del termine.
Vi faccio l'ultima domanda
e poi vi lascio:
Quanti di voi sanno
cosa è successo
il 23 agosto 1989,
un mercoledì mattina,
nei tre stati baltici?
Potete alzare la mano,
per cortesia?
Su, lo so che sembra
stupida come domanda.
Ancora un po'.
Siamo partiti al 100%.
Ve l'ho appena raccontata la storia.
(Risate)
Su, bravissimi.
È così.
Grazie di essere parte
di questa storia.
(Applausi)